well we're on overtime overseas now I
have to say I'm partly doing this
because I'm going to be touring overseas
there in Europe in May Sweden a place
I'm going just cancelled an arms deal
agreement with Saudi Arabia why isn't
the u.s. doing the same hmm could it
have something to do with oil no no it's
our love of their social policies
I'm doubtful I mean I and you know when
you look at the map and you see this
Yemen thing and why did all the Sunni
countries get involved because if you
look at the map well the oil goes
through the Straits of Hormuz which Iran
controls and these Houthis are Iranian
backed if they controlled Yemen then
they'd control the one through the Red
Sea this is all about oil when oil gets
involved people care but I always say I
wish we had learned the lesson of the
first Gulf War which is if you're going
to invade a country for oil get some oil
Zachary Quinto what can you tell us
about your role in the movie about
Edward Snowden oh yeah I'm playing Glenn
Greenwald to all your frequent
contributor here and many other places
I'm really looking forward to it getting
ready to go to Hong Kong and I'm not
know anything about this movie this is
we're Oliver Stone's directing and he's
written it oh yeah
however starting I love Oliver - I know
me too I'm really excited about it at
home to play Glenn who's so prolific in
right has such a really articulate and
and fixed point of view on everything
that he's done with Snowden and around
exposing the NSA's overreaching is
interesting for me yeah he forward to it
yes some really stupid point of views -
we're nice icing on those I like clever
but good what now there's some totally
ok how should Europe respond to Putin's
aggression well I would say first of all
its Europe's problem once again not our
problem
tough sanctions Oh basically that's true
um in his long since time for us to pull
the troops out of Europe they've been
there 67 years since World War two but
it went in when Europe was poor and weak
Europe now it's collectively able to
defend itself except the Europeans have
figured out as the favorite book in
Europe is Tom Sawyer because they have
persuaded us to paint their fence and
act like they were doing that
a vet sixty-seven years four billion
dollars right but I watched it I do
believe what the Russians are doing in
Ukraine is awful
I think economic sanctions are
legitimate and what the Europeans ought
to be doing is joining in sanctions and
probably putting some troops in
Lithuania Latvia or other democratic
nations before Putin moves to kind of
determine and yeah they should be taking
the lead but yeah I mean you you tried
to pass a military reduction bill and
you know it's very disappointing to see
even Rand Paul who I thought was our big
hero on this issue now is reversing
himself something I think father would
never do I think backing more military
speech meaning the American people the
American people I think agree with us
they don't want to sending ground troops
back in this kind of scare tactic that
the terrorists are going to come and
destroy the country I think is wearing
thin and I believe when we keep pushing
that you can make the casements my book
is might make theory about how you get
back into get people to like government
stop wasting 100 billion dollars a year
unnecessary in the mood to do it to help
people go to school do it to build roads
do it the thing and I think it's the
right candidate says that the public
wins and and one of the reasons why
Germany among other nations can spend so
much more infrastructure on green energy
is because they don't have to spend what
they did on the military we covered
their military ties that yeah we
basically Saipan old saviors I want to
make I want to be forgiving I'm not
always 40 whatever 50 some-odd 62 years
after World War two I forgive Japan I
forgive Germany they don't have to be
disarmed they don't have to rely on us
they can have their own weapons and we
can pull back right absolutely
okay what explains the rise of the
anti-immigrant National Front party in
France and should we be worried but
maybe maybe the death of you know over a
dozen Jews in France I mean you know and
and cartoonist
well Jews at the supermarket and then
the cartoonists at Charlie Hebdo right
that was a pretty significant event yes
in France and that can spur some maybe
anti-immigrant sentiment and I think
marine lepen is maybe capitalizing on
what is some very real fear for Jews in
Paris and and liberals in Paris I agree
but it's also I think those that
exacerbated it but I think it's the same
situation we have again and we don't
start quoting my book but we have this
problem with working people who have not
had a chance to participate in the
prosperity that comes forward because
the economies in developed Western
worlds have tilted in favor of people
with high end skills so the people who
forty years ago could go to work in a
factory and make a decent living they
have problems doing that and I believe
economic dissatisfaction is a large part
of the tea party and it's a large part
of what's going on there yes there were
don't equate those two please don't do
that I don't think you want to make that
mistake wait till my Senate George and
Isis I wasn't about Isis I wish - no no
I'm talking about the Tea Party and the
French right that's the equation okay
that I've actually the dissatisfaction
that's meaning people to be so angry is
I think it moved economic and again I'll
go back that's why I want to pull back a
hundred billion dollars that we're
wasting I think I want to be the
strongest nation in the world but we
don't have to be quite as strong as we
are and if we use that money to deal
with economic problems at home it would
be good in itself and would alleviate a
lot of that distress and to be fair
there is a comparison
there is a comparison to be made of
between religious fundamentalists of
Christian stripe and Muslims drive
within they both will believe I mean I
was just reading Mike Huckabee's book
and he says you know God was on our side
and and helped us fight battles we win
battles we should have lost okay do you
think God is attempting the scales he'll
tell you win battles that is something
that Isis if you say which ones they
wore was like run a canal or run with
you I mean I by the way Illinois should
we put the Tea Party I fight with them
on they don't kill people um but I do
put me on it
directly it's about and tall it's about
it's about an unwillingness to have any
perspective other than your own and
that's what the similarities are eyes I
agree but you still draw a distinction
between people who are yes bigoted
intolerant and people who kill other
people that's such a pretty big line
just wish that that the left would have
the same attitude toward Islamic
extremism as they had toward the
Catholic abuse scandal right that's all
I hope you're not looking at me cuz I'm
the one on the left
I'm with you oh and by the way sorry
President Obama is the one who has been
bombing them and killing them I think
this notion that the left has been soft
on Islamic extremism is wrong I agreed
with Bill's criticism no but policies in
the church the Pope needed to be
accountable for the action of a few
priests who were molesting children and
it is not the case that Islam itself can
be held accountable you can't have that
Khalid the people have been - even
though it's just been right a couple of
Muslims if you want to say you can't
make the equation which is a beautiful
Kanoa nickname Europe doesn't have maybe
they do and I'm not aware of it but it
seems like they have the people who they
like dirt will ders was in my movie
Religulous they say he could be the
prime minister of amped of Holland I'm
going to Amsterdam in another country
I'm City I'm going to UM a lot of people
think he's a crazy but I don't think
he's a crazy person I just wish there
was somebody who could make this case in
a way that wouldn't have them be put way
out there
bigot because there is a case to be made
no question I've made it I've been about
it clearly there was an element in this
lemon and particularly those people who
are Islamic Muslims who say this is an
origin have done a very poor job of
differentiating themselves if they want
if they would lead the fight against
these people they could then prove that
this was the case but are you just as in
the Catholic Church the victims of these
priests were Catholics the same is true
right victims of Islamic extremism are
by and large must not and since this
issue blew up I must say I hear from an
awful lot of Muslims who say yes you're
defending me because I'm a liberal
Muslim I want to live in the 21st day
and all that well publicly who are
shouting who call you a bigot are
shouting down the debate that we need to
have but they and I but I would urge
them to do it because there has to be
there was an intimidation within the
Islamic community and they have to speak
out more and do this there's no question
okay for Jay what does water have to do
with the conflict in the Middle East
well I know Syria that the war in Syria
was partly because there was a horrible
horrible drought right there not that's
right and it works like a million
farmers did it 'yes that's right and the
Assad regime had no commitment to
providing the water to those farmers
they want right I want to move away from
the agrarian society to a more global
economy and so they Martha far these
young farmers mygrades the cities they
sat around with nothing to do they got
upset you know watching other concerns
maybe the most catastrophic impact on
our civilization that we've seen yet I
mean if you look at just the the most
modest projections of water rise in the
oceans yeah it stands to displace
hundreds of millions of people
throughout the world a catastrophe that
governments are not equipped no matter
what party is running that a dead end
all that's it
anyway that's an excellent point and
whether we're talking about climate
change whether we're talking about water
availability and they're intimately
related we are not really prepared for
that for that future where we have to
maybe migrate around it's already having
to move the better around roads ago
absolutely north question in matter
right but so water Northwest Indian
Bangladesh absolutely right and that
there's a country the little dot of a
country in the Pacific at voulu or
something they just don't know how to
what is it I think it's Vanuatu
Vanuatu right god bless you
god bless their they just had a horrific
cyclone and they they could be
completely digested I'm here pick up on
what Jay said to us again um and this is
one of the things we know we talked
about in advance this isn't going to get
solved in a context or even begin to be
alleviated in the context in which is
fashionable to denounce government this
is only going to happen we have a
political concept consensus that we will
come together and pull our resources the
private sector they do a very good job
of creating wealth but left to their own
they will exacerbate this because the
pursuit unregulated of the profit motive
it's not immoral but it has negative
effects the externalities everything
else so this is one of the reasons why
for my book I think it's so important
for us to reverse this any government
trend because that but you said
government's are not doing a good job
some governments aren't even trying and
the government's that are trying lack
the political resources to get it done
okay
final question from Max is the u.s.
behind other Western countries when it
comes to gay rights uh yeah I think
certainly some of them certainly I mean
we can - Navion countries or yeah but
we've we've made a lot of we've covered
a lot of ground in the last ten years
yes laughter certainly is incredibly
encouraging I think this summer stands
to be a kind of defining moment for the
the legal battle know when you think
about 2004 with me only a decade ago
George Bush was able to win re-election
because Karl Rove was smart enough to
put gay marriage on the ballot remember
that in 11 states and every redneck got
to vote again game and I mean Bill
Clinton without widow haha Bill Clinton
was right oh excuse me is why I couldn't
you signed DOMA after the Republicans
forced it through Bill Clinton did not
invent DOMA bob dole did bill couldn't
did sign it after the Republicans passed
it just wait for reason why you why
using him for that life ran against gay
marriage for president so did President
Obama the great thing right that both
parties to a lesser extent the
Republican parties have moved so far so
fast I mean
lightning speed I'm sorry sire excuse me
but that's totally untrue the
Republicans have moved not at all they
remain every Republican presidential
candidate that's really against Saint
expect and as far as the Democrats are
concerned but I just named like ten
Republican senators and not from
Caliphate don't vote anyway come out in
favor of gaming you don't want to take
that little bit as a gift I am saying
that it is wrong for Mesa Murkowski I
mean you don't you don't think that's
good it's better than it was but the
fact is that every Republican candidate
for president is still very much against
us they vote against any legislation
that will be supportive and the other
point on the Democrats is yeah they took
a while to get the same-sex right but
even as they were not for marriage they
were opposed to the Republican efforts
to pass constitutional amendments that
would have canceled marriage so the
Democrats have been a not as good as
they should be and be in every respect
much better than it's also a social
issue it's also it's also about how
homosexuality has been portrayed and
perceived by the public and certainly in
large part by the entertainment industry
if you look at the advancements in how
gay stories have been told I mean Glee
just ended say what you will about Glee
it's a it was it people loved it for a
long time but what it did was it put a
face to millions of people every week
that had not yet been seen in that way
really and I feel like it's as much a
social wave as I thought it was about a
high school was it a gay show no but
there were tears transgender characters
always it was a pioneering show in terms
of Rio characters on the show having gay
relationships I mean it's one example of
many it's what about a show about gay
pioneers that's where again they're in
development on that show a quick hoping
to bring you on us and all right thank
you very much everybody thank you panel
you